よろしくお願いします
ある日 お釈迦様が弟子たちにこういうエピソードを申し上げます
教えましたけど で お釈迦様は悟りを開いて
間もないうち ウルヴェーラという場所で悟りを開いたんでしょうし
そこでネーランジャラという川が流れていて
そちらにたぶん菩提樹という風にもありますけど
ガヤシー まあイエスの側
ちょっと違う川ですけど
今ガンジス川もありますけど
そこでも歩きの下で座ってるんです
この木も大変な有名な木なんですけど
今はないんですからね
その時は大変有名なバラモンたちのグループがお釈迦様がいたところに行ったんです
バラモンたちが大変年寄りで
かなりの長老たちなんですね
で バラモン人たちっていうのはみんなに尊敬されている人々で
宗教家ですからね その中でも年取れば取るほど尊敬のレベルが随分高くなるんです
他のバラモンという誰でもちゃんと礼をするんです
そのバラモンたちが王様のお釈迦様のところに行ってお釈迦様と話をしたんです
お釈迦様は出家だからね
バラモンたちは在家ですから
出家の人々と色々話をするのは仏教です
それでそのバラモンたちがお釈迦様にこういう風なことを言うんですね
私たちは お釈迦様が年目上の人々を年上の人々に何も礼をしないと
尊敬しないと 礼をすることがない
挨拶することがないと
来たらすぐ自分が座っているところから立って
どうぞおかけくださいとかね
先に言うのは礼儀なんですね
年上の人に対しては そういうのを何もしないと聞いたんですよと
それで 実際行ってみ 行ってみたらその通りだと
お釈迦様のところにお釈迦様がいましたからね
聞いてみたら やっぱりその通りと
本当は年上の人々に礼をしないんだと
そういうことはちょっと良くないんだよと
お釈迦様にちょっと教えてあげるんですね
うーん お釈迦様は若いですからね
バラモンたちはかなり年上の人々だと思いますしね
まあ悟って まあその 1 年目の間で受けたできることでしょうし
そこでお釈迦様がこういう風に考えたんだと
ワタメーアーヤスマントウ ジャーナーティ テーランワ テーラカラネーワ ダンメー
このバラモンたちが長老ということは知らないんだと
長老になる方法も知らないんだと
中国語で長老と言うんですけど
パーリ語でテーラと言うんですね
それはまあ 年上という意味でもあるし
尊敬に値するという意味もあるしね
目上という意味なんですね
だから挨拶して礼をして尊敬する人になる
なった人がテーラであって
このバラモンたちがテーラということを知らない
テーラになる方法も知らないと
お釈迦様はこういう風に教えるんです
ブッドー チェーティ ビックリホーティ アシーティコーワ ナウティコーワ ヴァッササティコーワ ジャーティア ソーチホーティ
ジャーティア 例えばブッドー
年寄りがいる アシーティコー
80歳か90歳か100歳か
生まれてから そういう年寄りがいるとします
ソーチホーティ アカーラワーティ
でも喋るときはその時期を計算しない
喋るべき時間がないかということは
ただ好き勝手に場所を気にしないでなんとか喋る
アブータワーディ それ実際に自分で確かめたものっていうことではなくて
まあ嘘を言うっていうことなんで
だから噂でも嘘なんですよ
自分で確かめてない限りは
それからアナッタワーディ
人のためになることは言わない
人のためになることを喋る
ある利益になることは喋れないということ
これアダンマワーディ
真理は語りません アダンマ
ダンマっていうのは真理
アダンマっていうのは真理でないということ
それからアヴィナヤワーディ
ちゃんとした道徳も語りません
まあそういう年寄りもいますね
まあよく酒飲んで遊んでいた方がいいんじゃないかとかね
まあ年 いくら年取ってもまあ悪いことをするのはやめないとかね
それ自慢にする人々もいますけど
ですから そういう人々は他の人にも同じことを言うんです
それからアニダーナワティン・ワーチャン・バハサティ
アニダーナワティン・ワーチャンっていうのは
まあ言葉の一つの この
まあ証拠を出して喋ること
例えを出して喋ることはしないと
例を出して 証拠を出して
まあ言ったことに ことを支える何かないんですね
例えば神様がいるんだろうと
勝手に言うんじゃなくて
こういうことでこういうことでいるんだろうって
この言った言葉を何かちゃんと支えてあげないと
そのふうなことを喋ると
それのアカーレーナ 言っている時
べき時ではない 好き勝手に喋る
それからアナコデーサン
うーん あの これはあの
だいたい あの 日本訳ちょっとわかりませんですけど
まあ哲学的な用語なんですけど
アナコデーサンっていうのは
あの 言葉はこの通用する領域っていうのあるんですよ
そこはちゃんと考えて喋るべきなんですね
で この中国のいろいろ人の話みたいに
あの禅のいろいろ話みたいに
まあ一つこのアナコデーサンなんですね
領域考えてないんですね
例えば人はご飯食べるべき
なんか合ってる言葉のように聞こえるでしょうに
でもリミット どんな領域でこの言葉有効か
どこで無効かということはないでしょうに
だから健康な人はお腹が空いた時が
時 ご飯食べるべきなんです
そうすると言葉の制限できてくるんです
それは正しい言葉なんです
人はご飯食べるべきって言ったら
もう頭のいい人じゃないんです
ものすごく病気になっている
だったらご飯食べたら困るでしょうに
それでお腹が満腹 その時ご飯食べるべきというその人の数字に通用しないでしょうに
ですから 言葉にはこうやってリミットがありますからね
どこでどんな領域で使いますかという
それはすごく気をつけて喋らなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうふうに喋らないんだと
それからアナッタサンヒタン
言っている言葉にもあまり意味がない
そういう年寄りがいるんだと
そこで次にアタコウソウ・バーロー
アタコウソウ・バーロー・テーロー・テーワ・サンカン・ガッチャティ
そういう人がただの年寄りやと
バーローという言葉を使ってあって
バーラというのは年下という意味なんですね
それから愚か者という意味もあります
その二つにパーリ語でサンスクリット語でバーラという言葉を使いますね
価値がないというのは言ってます
だから大体子供たちにバーラって言うんでしょうし
年下の人には先輩がバーラという言葉を使いますね
後輩ということで で 一般的にはバーローということは愚か者
愚か者 愚か 愚か者という意味でパーリ語では使っています
で わざわざその言葉を使うのは
それは年下 まだまだ青いという意味も入っているんですね
できていないと まだ ですから
そういう人がバーロー・テーロー
テーローというのは長老って意味なんですけど
尊敬の長老ではないんです
愚か者という あるいは年下やと
年下の老人やと すごい否定な言葉なんですけどね
まあ適当に日本語はないんですけどね
まだまだ青臭い年寄りだっていうふうな意味なんですね
ですから 尊敬に値しないと
その人の話を聞く必要はないんだと
という意味があるんです
だって言っていることは
もう言葉はもう領域考えていないし
特にこの子供たち 若者に年寄りはいろんなことを言うでしょうに
みんな逆らうのは領域考えて言わないんですね
あれダメ これダメというだけで
いつまでかとかね どんな時かとかね
そうやってこの そういうと聞くんですよ
遊ぶなよと言ったら絶対聞いてくれない
あなたに宿題があるんだから遊ぶなよと
言ったら聞いてくれます
その場合はもうちゃんと遊ぶなよということは
宿題がある限りは遊ぶなよという意味ですから
遊ぶなよと言ったら もう死ぬまで遊ぶなよということでしょうに
だから聞くわけないんですよ
逆らっちゃうんですね
ですから この そういうふうに喋れない人は尊敬に値する人じゃないと
それからダハルー・チェーティ・ディッキャ・エーホーティ・ユワ・スス・カーラ・ケーソ
それからダハルー 子供がいる
若者がいる ダハラっていうのは大体子供に使う言葉なんですけど
かなり若者 子供がいる
青年ぐらいのに 若者ですね
こちら言っているのは
ユワ 若い スス・カーラ・ケーソ
ススっていうのは墨なんですけど
墨の色の髪の毛を持っていると
あれも髪の毛すごい黒い
バッデーニ・ヨッベーニ・サマンナーガと
もうバリバリの若者やと
バッダっていうのは随分もうピカピカ光っている若さという
ヨッベーニナっていうのは若さで
サマンナーガと ものすごくもう
もう もう かなり光っている若さで
若者がいる でも パトミー・ユナ・ウェーサ
人生のこの 大体三つに分ける場合は一番目の年に入りますね
少年・中年・老年と言えば
この少年の方に入る年で
ソーチ・ホーティ・カーラ・ワーディ
でも その子はちゃんとカーラ・ワーディ
ちゃんと時空関係考えて喋る
ブータワーディ 自分で確かめたものを本当のことを喋る
アッタワーディ みんなに役に立つことを喋る
ダンニャワーディ 真理を語る
ヴィネワーディ 道徳を語る
ニダーナティンワーチャンバハシタ
いつでも自分言っていることは何か支えがあって
何か例えがあって 何か証拠があって
こういうことで私はこういうことを言ってますよという風にちゃんと喋る
その喋る時でもカーレーナ
ちゃんと時期を見て喋る
サーパデーサン ちゃんとこの領域ですね
言葉はどこまで通用するかっていう
その領域もちゃんとあって入れて喋る
それからパリヤンタワティン
言葉には終わりがあります
前にはその 前にはそこなかったんです
アポリヤンタワティン
喋るは喋るはもうキリがない
また喋ると だからパリヤンタワティンというのは
言葉には始まりがあって
もうちゃんとした終わりもあります
それからアッタサンヒタ
言っていることは大変役に立つ
アタコーソーパンディトー
テーローテーワサンカンガッチャティ
その人に賢者やと 頭の良い賢い長老だと言うんだと
だからバールに反対のことはパンディタ
パンディタっていうのは賢者っていうことで
これとものの反対 その人が長老だと
まだまだ若いんですけど
ピチピチ元気な年で もう遊び盛りの年にいるんだけど
やっぱりその人が長老だよと
言って まあそういうことで
お釈迦様が年食っただけで
あの 偉いわけじゃないんだと
人間には何か知恵がないとね
何か宝物を心にないと意味がないということを言ってるんですね
それからまあその ところで
この言葉についてお釈迦様が
あの まあお釈迦様は自分のことをおっしゃってますからね
結局は あの この場合は
あの まあ随分若いし またパタマウェサというこの一番目
人生の一番目の方に入っているし
中年ではないし ですから
まあそれでも自分が長老であってアンタカではないということを言っているんですね
まあその時もお釈迦様の言葉について
この最初から随分まあよく考えてね
で そういうのはまあ興味ある人々にとっては大変意味があると思いますけど
で 役に立つかどうか分かりませんですけど
あの ただ喋るっていうことっていうのは
まあ仏教は認めない ただまあ何でしたっけ
面白いとかね まあカチャカチャと喋れるんだから喋ると
それ だからこれ喋るべきかないかと
何でも喋る必要はないしね
それも考えなくちゃいけない
だからカーラワーディー
喋るべきでもやっぱり喋る時期があるんですね
いつでも喋っていいわけでもないんですね
そこら辺計算しなくちゃいけない
だからカーラワーディー
ブータワーディー サッチャワーディーという
その言葉について どこでもパーリ経典では
そこはもうあっちこっちあっちこっちの出てくるものなんです
それからこのパリアンタワティン・ワーチャン・バハシティというのは
それもお釈迦様よくおっしゃる言葉で
パリアンタワティン・バハシティ
いわゆるリミットがあることを喋ると
まだ喋りたい まだ喋りたいって
もう喋る権利ある人じゃないんですね
ポイントがあって このポイントは喋りますって言ったら
まあこれぐらいで喋りますよと
そうやってきちんとリミットがあって喋るっていうことは
言葉に対してお釈迦様の立場なんです
それから真理を語らなくちゃいけない
嘘を言ってはいけない
で 真理も二種類あります
一つは ただ日常生活の本当のことを喋る
もう一つ ダンマワーディーっていうのは真理と私は訳したんだけど
ダンマを語らなくちゃいけない
ダンマっていうのはやっぱり生命に対する正しいことなんですね
人々の人生 生き方 来世
そういう何か役に立つように生き方を喋らなくちゃいけない
それからヴィネーっていうものを喋らなくちゃいけない
人間というのはどうしても堕落する方向へ行くんだから
そうならないようにきちんと生き方
道徳っていうのを喋らなくちゃいけないっていうのは
言葉に対する仏教の立場なんです
それからテーラ テーラワーダという立場に
尊敬に値する立場になる場合は
四つの項目があるんだと
この四つの項目が揃っていると
その方を尊敬すると それからまあ
お釈迦様は仏教のことを言うんですけど
イド・ビッキャヴェ・ビックー・シーラヤーホーティ・パーティモッカ・サンガラ・サンユット
まあ比丘たちのことを言うんですね
比丘がいて 大変戒律をちゃんと守っている
パーティモッカ・サンガラ・サンユット
お釈迦様がおっしゃった戒律セットがあります
二百ぐらい それにパーティモッカというんですけど
で 一応出足を支えてくれる戒律っていうものがありまして
それはちゃんと守る それからアチャーラ・ベーチラ・サンパンノ
行儀がいい 喋るとき 歩くとき
座るとき ちゃんと行儀のいい生活をする
アヌナッテス・ワッジェス・バエッダッサアビ
小さな悪いことでも やっぱりしてはいけませんと
それはもうたとえ小さいことでもしちゃうと
まあそんな大したことじゃない
軽いことだからやりますよという気持ちになっちゃうと
もう堕落する可能性ありますから
小さな悪いことでもやっぱりしないように気をつける
それはもうやばいと思うと
それからサマーダエ・スィッカティ・スィッカーパデス
お釈迦様がおっしゃった
このまあサイキョの場合はスィッカーパデ
戒律項目がありますから
それはサマーダエ・スィッカティ
受けて守る 次にこのバフッストーホーティ・スッタダルー
よーく聞いてるんですよと
話 いわゆる比丘たちのことを今言ってるんだから
比丘たちはお釈迦様の話をよく聞いてっていうのは
昔勉強することっていうのは聞くことだから
ものすごい勉強している人っていうのはバフッスタっていう言葉なんですね
バフッスタっていうのは勉強家っていうことなんですね
だからものすごく勉強している
それからスッタダルー
勉強したものをきちんと覚えて理解している
スッタサンニチェヤって理解してもいる
かなり真理を勉強して
心の中であつめて整理して持っている
どんな真理かというとはエテー
まあそれ ニッバン
エテー・ダンナ・アーディ・カルヤーナ・マッジェ・カルヤーナ・パリヨサナ・カルヤーナ・サッタ・サヴジャンジャナ・ケーワラ・パリプンナ・パリシダン・ブラマチ
ャリアン・アビヤダンティ・タタールーパッサ・ダンマ・バフッスタ・ホンティ
それで 世の中で説法といえば真理といえばいろいろありますけどもね
お釈迦様だけではなくて
ジャイナ教の開祖さんは説法してましたし
いろんな宗教の方々は説法していたんです
どんな説法でも宗教家が言うことはダンマと言うんです
ダンマって言えば 説法
説教というふうな意味で取ってもよろしいし
だいたい宗教家 精神家が
精神家ある程度ないね
まあ宗教家いう言葉にはダンマという言葉
一般的なパーリ語で使う
ですからお釈迦様が喋る言葉もダンマなんです
[終始背景音楽]ダンマは法
プレハット真理なんですけど
そこで何でもダンマって
ダンマはダンマなんですけど
どんなダンマもどんな説法もいいわけじゃないんです
こちら言うのはアーディカルヤーナ・マッジェーカルヤーナ・パリウサナカルヤーナ
どんな教えにしたって入り口があって
それから真ん中っていうところがあって
終わりっていうものがあるんですね
結論みたいなもの ですから
はじめがあって 真ん中と終わりがある
それをどんな教えにも大体やることで
最初はこの教えに入る人はどうすればいいかと
最初はあなたは初心者に何を教えるんでしょうかと
こういうことを教えます
それでいくらか勉強できていたら何を教えますかと
こういうことを教えますよと
そういういくらか勉強できた人に最後に何を教えます？最後にはこういうことを教えますよと
という風な この まあ はじめ中と終わりという 3つ
教えというものにはあります
で それはまあもう一つ
お釈迦様の考え方で 大体人々っていうのはそういうふうに考えているかどうかわかりませんですけど
本当にもう例えばちょっとしたテキストを読んだだけで
5 6ページ  7 8ページぐらいの
まあ全部その人の教え
その宗教わかるように
まあ待っている場合もあるし
まあ日本もいつでもそういうことだけ期待しているでしょ
あの仏教のすべてがわかる本といって
100 ページの本なんかあるんですね
だからいかに無知の世界かってわかるんですね
仏教のすべてが 100 ページでわかるわけじゃないしね
で それまたまあもう 400円で売ってるぐらいの
まあ本で まあそんなものを読んで
それ全てわかってるんだということで
まあ私たちに攻撃までされる場合もあります
まあ仏教の世界っていうのはそういうふうな簡単なものでもないんですけど
やっぱり初心者にはそれなりのそういう教えがありまして
いくらがわかってる人にはまた教えがあって
わかった人にはまた教えがあるというふうには
もう三段階はあるんですね
だから普通の講演にしたっても
やっぱりはじめがあって
初めはみんな内容が深くわかるわけじゃないでしょうに
ですから みんなの知恵に合わせて喋って
それからその講演のテーマにみんなはちょっと連れて行って
最後に言いたいことが最後にポイントを出さなくちゃいけないっていうのは
まあ話し方の まあお釈迦様が決まってた順番なんです
世の中みんなそういう風に喋るという約束はないんですけど
まあうまくまとめて喋りたければ
まあその順番を守った方がいいと思います
で かなり難しいと思いますけどね
智慧がないと 人と話す場合は
最初に相手の立場から相手が理解しているレベルから始めなくちゃいけない
相手が賛成するところから始めなくちゃいけない
それからどんどん自分が全く違う意見を言うならば
ゆっくりとその意見までいけば
ちゃんと思考を運べば
導けば まあうまくいくんです
今見えるのは いきなり自分の意見言う
みんなこれ何？ということをびっくりするんですね
それでみんな失敗するんですね
そこでこの教えが まあこの仏教のことを言ってますけど
アーディカルヤーナ 初めの部分も大変立派で
何一つも間違ってるとこはない
マッジェーカリアナ 真ん中のところも大変立派で完璧で素晴らしいもので
パリヨーサナカリアナ
最終的には無執着の涅槃のことを教えてますから
それももう最高な境地で
で まあそれはきちんと
初め真ん中終わり 全部完璧に教えている教え
それからサッタ 一言葉一言葉にすごい深い意味がある
それからサッギャンジャナ
かなり単語を誤解しないようにきちんと単語を選んでいる
で 誤解に 誤解しやすい好き勝手に解釈す-できるような単語は選ばない
だからお釈迦様のた-立場というのは
だい できるだけ日常生活で
あの 使う単語を選ぶんですね
で 普通はみんなこのすごい難しい単語
難しい表現 格言いうのはなんかかっこいいと思ってますけど
まあお釈迦様は逆の立場で
この日常生活で使っている
あの言葉できちんと真理を語っていたんですよ
だからパーリ語ってのは
まあ当時でも簡単にわかったヴィンヤーナとかね
あの サンニャーとかね
そういう風に日常生活の言葉なんですね
だから  ヴィジャナーティ
サンジャナーティ サンジャーナンと
それでサンニャーと それだけの定義でお釈迦様終わっちゃったんです
チンチャピクェサンジャナーティ
ニーランピサンジャナーティ
ピータンピサンジャナーティ
そういうふうに そういう風にわかりやすいと思いますけど
まあそれはまあいやがってる後の仏教の人々が
まあよく知ってやるぞと思って
まあむちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃ説明するんですけど
ですから このサッギャンジャナ
言葉はき-綺麗に言葉を使ってやります
ケーラパリプンナン 喋るものは完璧に喋る
もう もう何も あっちが問題ある
こちら問題ある こちらから疑問が現れるということではなく
きちんと喋ると それ-それが法の
仏教という教えの特色なんです
だからそこを私は まあ私はあまり出来の悪い人だから
こういう言葉でお釈迦様の言葉にチャレンジできればしてみてくださいと
お釈迦様の言葉一つとって
この言葉はこういう角度から見ればおかしいですよと
正しくないんですよと
どんな時代で誰にでも言えるんだったら言ってみてくださいと
自分持ってる もう地球上のすべての知恵をす-絞ってきて比べてみても
どうぞやってみてくださいと
できないと思います 批判する人が自分が間違っていることになるだけ
決して改良できません
完璧に喋っている パリプンナン
パーフェクトに喋っている
だから仏教を改良しようという人は全部仏教を堕落しただけで
だからブッダの教えを置いておいて
この他の教え信仰することになってしまっちゃうんですね
それでパリスッダン・ブラフマチャリアン
清らかな修行方 いわゆる修行といったってもブラフマチャリアっていうのは
この 何といいますか 今は修行に使う出家に使う言葉なんですけど
あの 修行してるんだとかね
出家者の生き方はブラフマチャリアだとか何とか言いますけど
ブラフマチャリアっていうのはノーブルライフという
この なんていう 優れた生き方
優れた生き方ですよ だからパリスッダン
完璧な 清らかな 優れた生き方を教えてるという
いわゆる心は完璧に綺麗になる方法を教えているんですね
アビヤダンティ そのような教えをタタールーパッサダンマ・バフスターホーティ
そのような教えをよく勉強している
ダハタ 覚えておこう ワチャサ・パリチタ
口で唱えて唱えて よく訓練しておく
だからお釈迦様の言葉っていうのは
勉強するだけではなくて覚えておいた方がいいんです
覚えておくだけじゃなくて
何回何回も繰り返す繰り返して
もう発音して あの 唱えて唱えて
ものすごく身に付いてもらった方が
かなり役に立ちます それだけじゃない
マナサ・ウペッキタ マナサ・ウペッキタ
マナサ 自分の心でよく観察してみる
言ったこと だから証拠あって喋ってるんだから
自分一人一人でも どういう意味でしょうか
そういうことでしょう
こういうことでは理解するのはすごい簡単なんです
自分でどういう意味でしょうかと理解する必要はないと思いますけど
当てはめてみるだけで十分なんです
みんな理解しようと 教えてやるぞとやってるんだから
仏教わかってないんです
私は小さな頃から仏教に一つも理解してやるぞってことじゃなくて
当てはめて当てはめてみるんですね
お釈迦様は証拠も全部出していたんだから
ただ まあ当てはめてみると
あぁ ぴったしすばりやと
そういうふうな あの理解の仕方なんですけどね
例えばみんなの理解っていうのは
例えばお釈迦様がこの
こういう言葉ありますね
あの タンナージャヤティーソーコー
タンナージャヤティーバヤン
タンナイリプンタスナティソーコークトーバヤンという
渇愛が憂いを生まれてくる
渇愛から憂いが生まれる
タンナージャヤティーソーコー
タンナージャヤティーバヤン
渇愛から恐怖 恐れが生まれてくる
タンナーリプムッタス
渇愛から離れた人 脱出した人には
ナティソーコー 憂いもなし
どこから恐怖感が出てくるんでしょうか
何もないんだと あれ平安だよってことなんですね
そうすると 一般の人々はこれをどうやって理解
渇愛が憂がもっていくとて
やっぱりこの世の中で渇愛がなければ生きていけませんねとかね
やっぱりいくらか いくらかいい渇愛のないんでしょうか
ないんでしょうかとかね
それは派手な欲っていうのは悪いとわかってますけど
まあ少々の欲っていうのは別にみんなそれで生きてるんだから
そんなもうもういい加減ですよ
だからわかってないのは
ブッダが何をおっしゃってるんでしょうかと
ブッダが解脱を教えてるんです
すべてのことから離れなさいよと
何ものにもとらわれたら苦しみが出てくるんだよと
解釈する人々は 世の中は素晴らしい
世の中は完璧 この世の中で幸せに生きることが
そこが人間の究極的な目的だよという立場でブッダの言葉を解説しようとする
そういう立場で解するんじゃもう仏教ではないでしょう
元々も 世の中は完璧だ
素晴らしいんだとかね
もう家族を育って もう金もうけて
もうみんなと色々遊びながら喧嘩しながら生きることこそ人間の目的やと
それこそ人生のゴールだと
目的やと いう立場でいるんだから
やっぱりまあそこそこの渇愛は必要ですよと
そこは失敗しちゃってはいけませんと
というところで偉そうなことを言おうとする
でももとからもう離れているんです
ですから そこら辺にも気づかない
気づかないで まあ少々の渇愛はいいんじゃないかと
そうそうの欲がなければうまくいかないんではないかと
もうそれは当たり前なんです
世の中の生き方が正しくて完璧で
それで何一つも問題ないならば
それに証拠を出さないでしょうに
じゃあ世の中で何一つ問題ない人が一人でもいるんでしょうかと
何にも困ることない ないことない人が
だからもう苦しみを伴う
伴わない幸せに何かありますかね
金持ちになりたければ
ボーンとものすごい四方が空から降ってくる場合がありますかね
そんなことないでしょうに
そう信じてる人がいるんですけど
その人は神様が許せれば
神様はもうちゃんと頭の上に降ってくれますけど
もう全ての財産 で 普通の人々はだいたい自分で頑張らなくちゃいけないんですね
金持ちになりたければ
で で 頑張ってうまくいくかいかないかと
で 家庭が平和で幸せでしたいなと思ったっても
これは苦しみ伴わないかね
いろんなことを苦労しないと平和な家庭を過ごすことは築くことはできないでしょうに
子供をちゃんと育てたいと思ったら
もう何の苦労もしないで
いい加減でわがままでやりたい放題で子供育てますかね
いろいろまあ苦労っていうのはあるでしょうに
ですから 苦労なしに まあ世俗的な一時的な幸せっても得られない
それなのに世の中完璧だっていうことはね
まあまあ成り立たない話で
証拠のない話なんですけど
そういう立場であのお釈迦様の言葉
タンハージャーティソーコまた同じ言葉ありますけどね
タンハー欲から苦しみ
憂いが生まれてくるんだぞとかね
だからそのそういうふうな解釈では間違いますけど
解釈の仕方もまたあるんです
で それは随分難しいんですけど
まあこれはもうプロとして勉強する場合は
まあ勉強するテキストあるんです
お釈迦様の言葉の解釈の仕方
分析の仕方 このだいたい 7つの分析して
あの論理はソーラサーハヤナ・チッタ十六の論理構成で
あの一言葉一言葉解説してあのいくんですよ
まあそれ簡単じゃないんです
ちょっとちょっと教えてあげようかなとね
私思ったんですけど 私の勝手で
でもできないんです まず単語ないことは一番大きな問題で
まあ日本語の単語を聞いたって誰一人教えてくれないし
私は一人で調べなくちゃいけないし
日本語自体にも当てはまる単語ないんですね
ですから まあそういう問題もありますし
それから内容っていうのはもう
骨が削れるほど難しい
でも理解できますけど
理解するためには大量の経典を覚えておいておかないと
もうバンバン証拠出しますから
証拠出せば あ そうですとすぐ分かってくれないと説明できないんだから
まあ無理だから ちょっと一つ二つ理解できただけでも紹介しようかなと思ったんですけど
それはまあ無理です そこで今説明したのは
このマナサアヌペッキタ
アヌアヌペッキタという言葉の説明
お釈迦様の教えを自分の頭でちゃんと観察して理解しておく必要があるんだと
観察する場合は観察の仕方があります
で 例えば欲から苦しみが生まれてくるんだぞと言ったら
自分が苦しんでいるために原因を調べてみれば
苦しむためになんで苦しんでいるんでしょうかと
これは欲から生まれているんだということを発見できると思いますよ
欲がないんだから不幸になった人が一人でも世の中でいるんだったら
まあブッダのことは無効になるんです
そこでブッダ お釈迦様がリミットあって喋るんだから
欲から憂いが生まれると
リミット リミットちゃんとあるんですよ
この領域っていうのは
人間にはいつでも憂いが生まれますよと常に言っちゃうと
リミットがないんです
人間には憂いがあると言ったら
これはもう間違っている言葉なんです
お釈迦様が言うのは 心清らかにしていない人にとっては
煩悩に溺れている人にとっては
ありのまま物事を見られない人にとっては憂いがあると
だから 一言葉一言葉厳密に気をつけてお話ししているんです
今私は証拠に出したこのタンハエターティソーコーという言葉にしても
きちんとこの この領域リミットではない
それのあの ちょっと あの哲学的 な用語あるみたいですけどね
例えば世の中花は綺麗ですとかね
無精神の言葉なんです
だから間違ってます 花は綺麗ですというと
世の中にある花と言えるもの
植物の生殖器官でしょ
我々花というのは そういうものは全て綺麗でなければいけませんよ
全ての花が綺麗わけじゃないんです
綺麗というのは人間の主観
それはそれでいいんです
花は綺麗ですとか 随分好き勝手にみんな言うでしょうに
だから我々の日常生活っていうのは
だからトラブル多いんです
お釈迦様の言葉の中で
そういう言葉はいくら調べても見つからないんです
だから仏教を勉強すると
かなり頭が鋭くなって
かなり明るい元気な人間になるはずなんですけど
それからディッティア・スッパティヴィッダ
で 仏教の真理っていうのはディッティア・スッパティヴィッダ
お釈迦様はディッティっていうのは悪い見なんですけど
邪見に使う言葉なんですけど
この場合は邪見ではなくて悟りなんですね
もう悟りの智慧できちんと経験して言ってるんです
いわゆる最初に自分で試してみて
あ これはいいやと 試してから言うんです
バンバン嘘を言いながら
あなた方嘘をつくなよという話はしません
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているすべて
お釈迦様が自分で試してから言っているものなんです
それからディッティア・スッパティヴィッダ
で 仏教の真理っていうのはディッティア・スッパティヴィッダ
お釈迦様はディッティっていうのは悪い見なんですけど
邪見に使う言葉なんですけど
この場合は邪見ではなくて悟りなんですね
もう悟りの智慧できちんと経験して言ってるんです
いわゆる最初に自分で試してみて
あ これはいいやと 試してから言うんです
バンバン嘘を言いながら
あなた方嘘をつくなよという話はしません
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているすべて
お釈迦様が自分で試してから言っているものなんです
そういう法をよく覚えている人
よく理解している人 よく唱えて身についている人
それからその意味を自分でちゃんと噛みついて理解している人ですね
それで その教えによってどうなるかというと
もう一つ次のポイント
チャトゥンナンジャーナーナン アビ・チェータ・シカーナン ディッダダンマ・スカ・ヴィハー
アン ニカーマ・ラービ・ホーティ アキッチャ・ラービ・アキ・アカシーラ・ラービ
あの四つの禅定があるんです
よく仏教で禅定っていうのは心の高いレベルなんです
透視だ状態 そのアビ・チェータ・シカ
普通の人のチェータ・シカという心のレベルよりもう飛び出して
もう超一流の心のレベルなんです
禅定っていうのは ですから
普通の人間の知識レベルはもう超えている
この禅定 四つの禅定があります
その禅定が自分で経験している
それでディッダダンマ・スカ・ヴィハーリ
毎日毎日ものすごく気楽に生きている
この人間が楽じゃないのは
この心の次元が低いんだからなんです
我々の心の次元というのは
この眼耳鼻舌身の次元にあのリミットされているんです
考えるために何か見なきゃ考えられない
何か聞かなかったら考えられない
我々は考えるものを 見たもの
聞いたもの 味わった嗅いだものなんですね
そんな大胆なことを考えてるわけじゃないんです
それ以上何も知ることはできないんです
だからその中で我々にとってはすごく苦しみ
もうごちゃごちゃいろんな問題っていうのは出てくるんで
楽な瞬間っていうのはほとんどないんです
心の中で 考えるとかなり苦しいんです
妄想した後 結構苦しいんです
それでも踏ん張ってやってます
いくら苦しくてもそれはやめられないんですね
やめられるためには この眼耳鼻舌身のこの
し・し・倫理 美意識 信というこの五つのリミットを破らないと
リミット破った瞬間であれは落ちるんです全部
悟らなくても禅定ぐらい作ったら
この妄想の回転やら苦しみの回転というのはすぐ消えちゃう
消えちゃってすごいあの体も心もものすごい安らぎな状態に
あの来るんです それでまあ常に
もういつでもすごく安らぎの心でいられる
だから四つの禅定 それはいとも簡単に経験して
いとも簡単に禅定に入ったりする人
それ三番目の項目 二番目の項目は仏教を知っていること
一番目の項目はきちんと道徳完成した人であること
番目の項目は仏教をちゃんと知っている人
三番目の項目は禅定に簡単に出入りできる
すぐ常に安らぎを味わっている人
四番目の項目 アーサヴァなんからは煩悩を全部なくして滅して
アナーサヴァ 煩悩でない
無漏でというんですね
チェート・ウイムッティ
心の解脱 パンニャ・ウイムッティ
智慧の解脱 解脱二種類と分けてます
チェートンとパンニャ・ウイムッティって
まあまあ解脱だけ理解しててもよろしいし
それがまた別な定義もありますけど
すべての煩悩から煩悩を滅して
無漏と言える煩悩 無漏っていうのは煩悩の漏れないって意味なんですけど
無漏たる煩悩を自分で
解脱を たる解脱を ディッティ・ゴダンニ
この世の中で生きて 生きな・生きていながら
これ死んでから得れる結果じゃないんです
仏教の悟りっていうのは
サワンナ・ヴィンニャー
自分で体験して サッチ・カッタは経験を得て
それにウパサンパッジャ入って
解脱を体験して生活すると
というのは四つの四番目の項目なんですね
その四つ揃っているならば
イミーコ・ディッティ・チャッタロ・テーラカーナ・ダンマ
この四つが長老尊敬に値する
ために必要な条件だよと
その条件四つ揃っている人には
もう頭を下げて礼をして敬って
もういろいろ教えてもらうしか見違えない
その人が来ればすぐ席を立って
先に席を与えて まあそうやって行儀作法をしなくちゃいけないと
そうした方が自分の役に立ちますからね
人間がまあ老人だからといって
もうもうアホだったら別に役に立ちません
だから年寄りを助けてあげることは仏教でよくよく言ってますけど
仏教はもっと尊敬するんですよ
年寄りの人っていうのは
両親やら目上の人っていうのは
だから うーん ただの年寄りだったら
まあちょっと面倒見てあげればいいんです
言う 話 言ってることを聞く必要はないんです
でも 本当の仏教でいう長老っていうのは
この四つの 尊敬に値するっていうのは
この四つ揃ってる人ですね
ちょっとまた項目変えて
それはまあ下にしてます
ウッダッターナ・チッターナ
心が混乱状態にある いわゆる禅定と反対
落ち着かない状態にある
サンパンチャ・バヒ・バーサチ
モーダーバーナシ よくよくたくさん大量にしゃべる
アサマーヒタ・サンカッポ
考え方を整理していない
サンカッパっていうのはコンセプト概念ということで
思考なんです 思考は全然整理していない
あれやこれやとかいろいろごちゃごちゃ考えること
アサッダンナ・ラトー
死んでは嫌 悪いことをしたいという
魔方 人が アラ・アーラソ・テーラ・ターヴァレイヤンハ
で ターヴァレイヤっていうのは
うーん それだけじゃなくて
この やっぱりチャレンジするべきにはチャレンジしないんですよ
例えばこのヴィパッサナーの人にはかなりチャレンジしないと
できないんですよ 根性が弱いんだったら
で かなりチャレンジしないとできない
できるものじゃないんです
だからまあ 格好つけてたっても全然意味がない
もうこれは結構必須仕事なんです
で だからやった人はすごい人格が出てくるんですよ
なんかすごいことにチャレンジした人は
それだけですごい人格者になるでしょうに
で こちらっていうのは
このターヴァレイヤっていうのは
そうやって精進するべきものにすることには精進しないで
それから離れているという
もう怠け者ですね 悪いことをしたいし
頑張ることには頑張れないしね
パータ・ディッティ 考え方も悪意しか持ってないし
アナダーロ まあ-いい加減な生き方をしているという意味です
これ ターワレイヤーマではなくてテーレイヤーマ派でしょうと思いますね
これ おそらく タハーラ
ま スタビリティ スタビリティと訳すればいいんですね
まあそういう特色ある人っていうのはテーラだと
あの 安定した長老やと言えないんだと
まあちょっと一言葉の意味が忘れちゃった
テーラ テーラっていうのはこの長老と訳せますけど
もう一つ辞書的に意味があるんですね
まあ安定という 安定しているという意味もあります
お釈迦様その意味取っているんですね
スタビリティという ステーブル
いわゆるガタガタしない
精神的にも人格的にもしっかりしている
芯があるという その意味でもテーラと言えるんですね
だから若者にも当てはまる
若いのしきしと物事を勉強して
もう真理語ると それまたきちんと証拠を出して語るんだったら
もう芯があるでしょうに
そしたら今説明したこの心は混乱しているわね
よく喋るが無駄話 それもたきりがなく
で もう考え方 概念も一つも整理していないとかね
悪いことばっかり好きで好んでやってるし
そういう人にとってはテーラとは言えませんよと
長老とは言えませんよと
この もう 安定した人とは言えないんだと
それで逆にヨッチャ・シーレナ・サンパンの誰かがシーレナ・サンパンの戒律を道徳を持っている
スッタワーパティバハナワ
スッタワーよく勉強している
そこにパティバハナワというと
またよくお釈迦様使っている言葉って
パティバハナワっていうのは瞬時にひらめく
勉強したっても頭の悪い人がいるでしょ
仕事に行ったら何もできないと
勉強はしたんだけどと
質問したらすぐ答えられません
ちょっと調べてから言いますよとかね
テキストでマニュアルなければ生きていられないでしょう
それはパティバハナって全くないんですね
すべてマニュアル マニュアル
マニュアル マニュアル
マニュアルであって これはこの場合はどうしますかと
これ日本のね 公のところに至っても
各仕事についてマニュアルがあるんです
その仕事はどうこなすべきかと
ですから 結局はみんな動物扱いされています
この社会で だからもうあなたには考える能力はない
あんた今課長なんで まあ公の場合はね
いろいろ部がありますでしょ
まあもう森保は行ったことがないんだけど
まあ例えば私がよく行くのはこの外国人のもう管轄のところに行く
そちらもまあもう佐藤みたいな部長みたいな人いるんで
やっぱりちゃんとマニュアルがあるんですよ
何か問題が出たらすぐテキストを開けてみて
えーとえーとですね はい
これはできます それ見てて私はなんだかバカバカらしくなっちゃいますけど
一応自分でそれぐらい判断できるでしょうということ
ですから まあ面白いっていうのは
何でもないもので マクドナルドでハンバーガー作ってるような感じで
どこら辺で 学生でもバイトに行くでしょうに
行ったらちゃんと人ハンバーグ作ってくれます
だから全部写真貼ってますからね
まずこれ入れて これを三分温めて
これ入れて それにこれ入れて
この紙で包んでテーブルに出すと
だからそれだったら人間と動物とはね
動物いろいろね サーカスなんかに動物もね
いろいろ芸やってるでしょうに
もうそんな状態なんですね
これ見たらこうしますと
あの あのイルカショーやらね
あの あるでしょうね 歌ってくれると
手でこうやって ちゃんとそういうんで
そのに合わせて歌ってることもなんでもないんです
あの この池袋にありますけど
イルカって言わないね
あれは シーライオン 日本語で何て言いますか
あの こうやってっていうのは
え ハスカかな うん そこであのアコーディオンじゃなくて
あの あれ あの鍵盤 あの
何と言いますか キーボードみたいなね
楽器がありますけどね
それちゃんと何かちょっとした曲を歌うんです
もう弾くんですよ それをかなり大きく
あのキーを作ってあって
鼻でこうやって押すんだからね
だから押すところはちゃんと決まってあって
そこであの この人はちゃんとこうやって信号出すんですよ
信号を出すと こちらとこちらと
だからこっち行ったらそちらのサインがあるんだから
それ見て押す こっち来てまた押す
こっち来てまた押すと
そうすると もうなんとなく歌らしく聞こえる
笑いながらすごい楽しい
そこで私たちもあっち行くと
あの人もこうやって自分にもって言われて
みんな笑って楽しいんですけど
まあまあ そういう生き方なんですよ
あれはもう可愛いんですけどね
別に本人が別にもう曲一つ弾いてるという気持ちはさっぱりわからないし
とにかく人間に言ってることをやってあげれば
まあサンマ サンマではなくてイワシですね
イワシ２ ３匹はもらえますよと
イワシもらいたければ
これをやらないといけないと
それぐらいのことでやってますけどね
だからマニュアル通り動けば給料もらえますよと
だから この何か問題が起きたら智慧があるかないかっていうことはわかるんですね
それは仏教でパティバハナ
智慧がある人っていうのは
問題が起きたから 起き時は起きた時わかるんだよと
どこ行ってもパティバハナというものを随分必要とするんですね
だからあの それは日本語で言えばひらめきみたいなもので
インスピレーションみたいなものでね
突然人が質問したらパッと答えてしまうと
そこでなければ もういろんな経典なんか
私 頭の中でもね 今もうこれ頭の中にしても調べるのは大変ですよ
かなりテキスト入ってますから
でも瞬時に出てきます
これだったらこれで答えるんだよと
それで私は全然パーリ語なんか言わんでしょうに
それは瞬時に日本文化に
日本の現代時代に変えるんです
変えて順番も決めて まずこれいて
次にこれいて 次にこれいて
この人は偉そうに質問したんだけど
質問内容さえもわかってないんだと
でも知った方がいいやと
だったらその人の思考はこうやって変えればいいんではないかと
そこまで計算して まあ瞬時に答えますけど
結果は全然うまくいってないんですけど
自分としてはそういう気持ちではいろいろチャレンジはします
それにはやっぱりすぐすぐ思い浮かんで
やっぱり予想しなかった問題が出たら
まあその場合はこうしますよというふうな
このひらめきの知恵っていうのはまた必要なんですね
ですから スオッターワっていうのはよく学問を身につけている
それだけ一人前になりません
パティバハナっていうものが必要なんです
あの 数学を勉強するときは
子供たちには一応方程式やらいろいろ問題解決する方法やらを教えてあげる
でも 質問出す場合は全く新しい質問なんです
その時は自分でどう答えるべきかと
今まで勉強したものを適用して
この問題はどう解いた方がよろしいかと
その瞬時に判断しなくちゃいけないんですね
その数学だけだったら
そのすぐ瞬時に瞬時に答えを出せる能力をチェックするんですけどね
でも 残念なことに 数学のプロっていうのは
この人生についてはプロじゃないんですね
これ数字で物事を考えるだけであって
この生きる上ではもう一つちょっと論理が違いますからね
その時はカンダス・パティバハナという機能は必要なんです
でなきゃ数学のプロにはなりません
プロのところがまあ数学の項目は合格することはできません
丸暗記して答えとか 試験に行ったって意味がないんだから
その質問出てこないんだから
それからサンニャと落ち着いている人
ディーロ 知恵のある人
ダンメーす パンナーヤッタ・ヴィパッサティ
真理に据えて あの 智慧でもって
ヴィパッサティ ちゃんと観察
ヴィパッサナーですね
観察をする それからパールブー・サッバダンマーナ
すべての現象の法を乗り越えている
えーと アキル・ウパティバーナは
またパティバーナが出てきます
アキル 何も障害なくない生き方
心 またパティバーナがあって
パヒーナ・ジャーティ・マラナ
輪廻を乗り越えている
もう生まれること 死ぬことはもう
もうない ブラフマチャリアッサ・ケーウェディ
もう清らかな生き方 完璧な清らかな生き方をしている
ケーウェディ 完璧な 完全な人
タマハン・ワダーニ・テーロ
その人こそテーロですよと
安定した人ですよと ヤッサ・ノー・サンティ・アーサワ
煩悩がない人が尊敬に値するべきテーロ
長老ですよと アーサワーナン・カヤー・ビクク
テーローティ・タウッチャティ
それで結論を出すんです
この長い経典ですけど
あの 長い経典ですけど
覚えておくためには このインデックスみたいな引っ掛けないと覚えにくいんです
だから最後にこの それも入れているんです
アーサワーナン・カヤー・ビクク
アーサワーナン・カヤー・ビクク・テーローティ・タウッチャティ
アーサワーナン・カヤー
煩悩滅した比丘がテーローという
いう いう なんていうか
テーローという だからテーロ
長老とか  テー  テーラという言葉を使わなければ
煩悩をなくした比丘に長老という
だからそれもちゃんとリミット
制限あってる格言なんです
誰も変更することはできません
じゃ それで話を終了しますけど
あの 言葉の使い方と  我々は誰を拝むべきかという疑問がありますからね
で 仏教は別にそんな神を拝むとかね
あんまりしません あの
ご利益のためにね で 仏教はやっぱり
その代わりにこの悟った人々
お釈迦様のこと もうちゃんと神の代わりにしてみなさいよ
そうすると何かあなた方に何かなるんだぞと
お釈迦様は認めません
ただ年取っただけで すごいとかね
家柄とかね ブラマン人っていうのは家でしょう
ブラマンの家族で生まれたらブラマン人だからね
生まれただけで聖人になるわけじゃないんだろうと
人間が努力によって立派になりますから
だから立派になった人を先輩にしないと
先輩というのは経験者であって
先にやった人でしょうね
その人から教えてもらわなきゃ
自分たちも成長はなくなっちゃいますね
そういうことで  煩悩ない人を尊敬しなさいということなんです
[背景の雑音][背景音楽]